hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back test ep containment
brick with new stuff a lot of new stuff
actually oh this looks good
I wonder if this episode's gonna start
as a van fully is the last one okay is
it just me or is it much darker in this
game and I have had it in the past
oh the computer on the commutator I can
talk to you hello oh hi dad guy how oh
you're next completely the wrong way
that's delightful if I remember oh wait
sir oh wait he doesn't let me in just
yet I need to turn off the power that's
right I need to turn off the power and
then go see him
sorry getting out of myself bring it on
you sdp bastards right after I save
those are new sounds one of the changes
said that it made new sounds hello if I
wanted to summon radical Larry I could
go in there okay that is a wall of
darkness oh no it's not it's SuperDuper
duck ah what's in here the rubber red
the red room huh what is this is this oh
okay ah oh I thought I fell through the
floor why did I think I fell through the
floor okay that's weird
nevermind I'm gonna ignore that ever
happened everyone ignore that ever
happened it was this uh cowbell this is
the thing I went Bing bong about and you
all were mad at me you were like no
don't ring the bing-bong er don't do it
you'll go die what if I what if I ring
the bing-bong again what do you what are
you gonna do if I rent what
a versioned moon I don't know that is if
I read that before I know it's going on
top at trying to get you on the
clipboard cowbell cobber you all want to
being Hmong it nothing ever happened
last time at Bing bong I'm up I'm gonna
Bing bong it a bit my mom my mom every
other SVP out dodgers goalie what can
you do
Bing mom my mom by now
I'm not bring it on okay
Bing bong bring it on Bing bong bring it
on
hey mom bring it on I'm not going in the
main this bells for you
Bing mom bring it on anybody anybody
bought a ping ball - bring it on bring
it on big mom watch stop moving my
camera oh hi
what was that gonna what why hi hi
I died
ah okay so I bing-bong died and they
bing-bong brought it on so that's what
that does
that's why I shouldn't Bing bong I'm not
gonna Bing bong any more my Bing bong
days are done
No
okay it wasn't the Bing bong it was just
that particular monitor why is that
particular monitor deadly I need to look
at that I need to know where he is cuz I
know what no no why is that one killing
me oh no Bing bong bring it on some more
what a Bing bong oh stop it
don't do that okay I'm just gonna go
through this for this guy I didn't see
him
I am boom this bull this bull honkey I
want to get through there oh I fell
through the floor and hopefully this
won't happen again
they keep saying that they fixed the
fall through the floor problem but they
don't hey do not
hey do not I saw this works this time
nothing about the quick loading I think
the long loading doesn't let you fall
through the floor but for some reason
the quick look very strange I think that
makes thicker floors and maybe that's
just another STP that they fed fully
like a running joke they always make you
fall through the floor shut up
I didn't Bing bong stop it stop puts the
flip-flopping okay all right take two
don't look at that particular monitor
because it's bad juju is he in there
where is he in there oh that monitor no
broken now no wanna kill me where is he
[ __ ] yeah where is he I don't see him in
there I'll stay him in there always in
the corner okay make it he's in this
corner
what the hell my vision keeps turning I
keep turning ah okay I'm gonna take that
as a sign that I'd stop it
top what's a head flipping I'm gonna
take that as a sign that I'm not
supposed to go that way and I should
find any other way but bad director I'm
gonna go this way no way no I'm not I'm
gonna go this way
another's way back okay no no there were
more options I rubber ducky are you
doing diabolical death just go over that
way oh yeah I forgot about that that's
new are you actually something the whole
lot is nothing in here Oh like it baby
hey was that the whole room was just a
double dealing of death an extra helping
what it was yeah right that's just
another dead end please don't be ah come
on
it's just dead and he's taken take care
of radical area gasps OH
now that he's been a problem I'm just
saying I'm here I might as well I don't
think I summoned him yet
I get to listen to this guy scream his
head off at his own agony oh poor baby
so I'm trying to my shrine Oh
hello hello get ready to have your
femurs broken
wait what was that coming but why am I
looking over there what am i doing
no debit Pablo you're over
what am i doing I'm not doing there
Krister god damnit dad okay god I'm I
think my vision is just totally Borka
fide it keeps sending me fast [ __ ] god
damn it what the hell is that
Oh No I trapped you I trapped you i
trapped you Oh God stubborn thank you
those new have they changed it in here
no I don't know oh good I'm here I
remember yeah I know the drill
I don't know if I'm gonna get out of
here I still hear that static in my ear
can you not have that there I tried to
tap you and it didn't work for some
reason it almost always worked before
ah well you know what alright then you
you have a lovely day you have you have
a delightful day dick ah now I refuse no
no no no no no no no no no
I just want to leave okay good
I why didn't this work it's supposed to
break your femurs and then as soon as he
gets in there if my vision would not
flip-flop
ah did I get them I didn't get him what
the hell there doesn't make any sense
is it bad no
okay forget it forget it forget it
apparently everything I do nowadays
doesn't seem to work isn't that
delightful I'm gonna go to the land of
unicorns and just have the time of my
life was I'm pretty sure the layout of
unicorn shut up
dub shut up Oh
standing there you didn't even make a
noise oh god damn it
I know it's where I gotta go now I gotta
go past the Cabal oh oh oh that might
have been the highest pitched scream
I've ever screamed in my life uh I
wasn't even do you
don't say again oh what a stop then it
wasn't even that like jump scary
quote-unquote it was just he was there
he was there and he was supposed to be
there okay so somehow I'm supposed to
get through this area this is what I'm
supposed to do a while ago didn't seem
to work
I'm reusing this one one okay it's right
dead smack in the middle I'm running out
of eyeball juice okay he's right around
the corner I can get that I can do this
just I can I can I can do that's nice
let's taste
fine it's fine we're gonna go back by
kill me it'd be easier to load
where am I now where am i now where'd
you put me would you put me oh okay I
know where you put me okay
though there's still one area that I can
go that I don't want to go uh tunnel not
that way
it was um as a way to the tunnel
basement area well how was it I know it
was here I started I remember it or was
it as computron oh shut up you bastards
you whispering bastards you shut that up
and go to hell and preferably stay there
and die another ping pong area how was
it where the hell was it it was here no
no no no I saw it I you know I said it
cuz I was I was like hey look at that no
way I'm going in there uh-huh
mace win I have that that's what I said
that's the thing that's what I said I
said that thing where the hell is it
oh yeah that's right it was over here
dogs right here by the other way okay
the ladies and gentlemen that's all the
time I have for this part and in the
next episode I will be going down into
the maintenance tunnel my favorite place
in the whole wide world I can't wait so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation videos that I've done and
as always I will see you in the next
video
bud
Oh